انتخب مجلس النواب الامريكي زعيم الاغلبيه
الجمهوريه كذب مكارثي رئيسا له بعد 15
جوله من التصويت استمرت خمسه ايام ليكون
الاقتراع هو الاطول في تاريخ المجلس منذ
عام
وتمكن مكافي من تامين الاغلبيه المطلوبه
بواقع 200 16 صوتا مقابل 200 واحد 10 ذهبت
ل حكيم جيفرست زعيم الاقليه الديمقراطيه
في المجلس وتمكن من الحصول على هذه
الاصوات بعد تصويت جزء من الكتله المعارضه
لصالحه بعد تقديمه تنازلات لهم في حين صوت
عدد اخر منهم بالحضور مما خفض السقف
المطلوب للاغلبيه وفي كلمته عقوبه سلمه
رئاسه المجلس الرسميا قال لما كان في ان
المجلس يعمل على مسائله الحكومه بدءا من
الانسحاب في افغانستان مرورا بتفشي فيروس
كورونا وصولا الى استخدام مكتب التحقيقات
الفيت الفيدراليه الاس بي اي كالسلاح
السياسي وفق تعبيرك
[تصفيق]